muted celebrations for the Socialists in
Spain who win once again the largest
share of the vote but not a majority
forming a government will be fraught
with difficulty the Socialist Party has
won the elections for the third time
this year I would like to thank the
millions of Spaniards who were summoned
and took part in these elections because
this is good for our democracy caretaker
Prime Minister Pedro Sanchez called this
election after earlier coalition talks
failed and believing the Socialists
would improve their standing in April's
vote the gamble hasn't paid off he will
now be under immense pressure to
negotiate a coalition likely to include
the extreme left you need espada most
party and even relying on Catalonia's
separatist parties for support
even if these parties the Socialists for
them most the most of the Catalan
nationalists are led leaning parties
they are very different they have
different interests the Catalans of
course wants independence this goes very
much against the Desai's of the
Socialists catalan separatists have been
hugely influential in this election and
the last one in April and it will be
unthinkable to many in Spain that they
might provide the key even if just
through some voting arrangement to
unlocking a socialist government in
Barcelona delight at what some will see
as a victory for the independence cause
and to make matters worse for the
Socialists the ongoing Catalan drama
that threatens the breakup of the
Spanish state has provoked a shift in
public opinion to the right the
conservative People's Party has been
rehabilitated and the far-right Vox
party has doubled its share of
parliamentary seats to become spain's
third political force
[Applause]
I think we can be very proud despite the
uncertainty we all face in the future
because a patriotic social alternative
has been consolidated in Spain that
demands national unity and the
establishment of constitutional order in
Catalonia with the unforgiving
application of the law no one wants to
see another election but whatever
governing arrangement arises out of this
fractious and fragmented political
landscape it is likely to be neither
stable nor long-standing Jonah hull al
Jazeera Madrid